- Okay, so if I were a
white person and I said,
"I wanna transition into a black person,"
and I'm redefining what
blackness is to fit
- Yeah.
- What I view it as, right?
Would you consider that appropriation?
- I consider that dodging,
and I consider that
comparing apples to oranges,
because race and gender identity
are two separate different things.
(inspirational music)
- [Narrator] Step forward if you agree.
The transgender movement is
indoctrinating our youth.
- We are seeing, especially
on social media, on TikTok,
you're seeing a lot of
people in this community
really just targeting children.
And you're seeing drag shows,
even in conservative states like Texas,
and even just media, movies,
like it seems like everything
seems to be targeted
at these kids.
You have a drag story hour for kids.
And it's just really, I
think, predatory in a way,
and I'm not saying every
trans person is doing this,
but as a whole,
there's does seem to be a route
that they're taking to get to the kids.
- And when you hear Blues
Clues playing in the next room,
and then you hear the gay
parade song, Blues Clues,
you're not expecting the to be talking
to the children about that.
- Yeah.
- It really makes you wonder,
are they really coming for the children?
- And I think we see
in our population now,
the rate of young children
who are identifying
as transgender, non-binary
is skyrocketing.
And I think there's something
to be said for people
who are truly experiencing
gender dysphoria,
which we recognize exists.
And those who are experiencing what
is now going to be called,
or in the future going to be
called this social
contagion gender dysphoria,
where they're being exposed
to it on social media
or in school or mom and dad
are having a conversation
about it with children.
And children are now starting
to develop gender confusion.
- Or even babies, right?
People who are being born,
they don't have to put the gender
on the birth certificate.
And they're saying, you can
choose whatever you wanna be.
Like that's so dangerous.
And even lying to them saying like,
"Oh, if we put you on
hormone blockers at this age,
it won't do anything to your puberty.
It won't affect you long-term."
And it's just a straight up lie.
And there's like an entire
Reddit thread dedicated
to people who've de-transitioned talking
about how much they hate their life now,
because they transitioned as a child
and now they amputated
off healthy body parts
and are miserable.
- All right, can the
disagreers step forward?
- The fact that the trans
movement has got people shook,
has me so excited.
The trans movement is not
indoctrinating our youth.
Our youth are understanding
who they are at a younger age.
And from what I was hearing over here is,
a lot of what y'all were saying,
I wonder, would you say it to the parents?
Because we need to really
look at what the parents
of trans youth really go through.
Trans youth, instead of
them enjoying their life,
playing with their friends,
they're up in legislation trying to fight
for basic rights here.
One in five transgender youth have tried
to commit suicide.
Why are we trying to police them?
- But you're bringing it
only to the parents being,
the question was
indoctrination in general.
Am I correct?
- But they're part of,
but they're a part of that conversation.
But someone said
something about drag shows
coming to schools or whatnot.
The kids enjoyed it.
The parents just had a problem with it.
But that's their issue.
It's only someone dressed
in drag reading a story--
- Is drag not blackface for women?
I see it as a caricature of womanhood.
- Inherently sexual as well.
- Insulting.
- I have to agree with you guys.
I do not like the drag
queen's social hours.
I personally, as a trans person,
didn't ever go to a drag
show until I was about forty.
I'm not for the sexualization of kids.
Why are we teaching,
why are we not letting kids be kids
and bringing sex into
their lives so early?
- I think it's predatory
in general to talk
about sex with children,
regards straight sex, any kind of sex.
(talking over each other)
- Who's teaching sex to
third grade children?
I really wanna--
- Have you looked at the
California curriculum
for sex education?
You need to.
- I know that when I was in preschool,
I got my first crush on a boy,
because to me at the time,
he was in kindergarten,
he looked like Prince Eric from--
- Little Mermaid.
- Yeah, Little Mermaid.
I don't think like *******
him ever crossed my mind
when I was four.
But obviously, like it
would've been good to know
that like it's okay.
Like if you have these feelings
for someone of the same sex.
- When we think of youth in general,
they're having sex at a lot younger age.
Whether we like it or not,
let's just keep it 100% real.
- You don't think because of that?
- I don't, I do not think
it's because of that.
It starts at home with parents
teaching their children.
Because one of two things is gonna happen.
Either you teach your children
or the world is gonna teach your kids.
That's the reality of it.
- They are learning about it
at younger ages from some adults
or even their peers who
learned about it from adults.
That is in definition, indoctrination.
As a mother and seeing
what my children are going
to have to be introduced
to at such a young age,
like I didn't even know what a gay person
was till I was like 12.
And so they're gonna be having
these really heavy adult conversations
at a really young age just
because of their exposure.
And that is honestly just scary,
because I don't want to
have those conversations.
That's why I will be
homeschooling my kids,
because I do believe
it is my responsibility
to protect them and shield
them from the outside world,
which is targeting children.
- The trans community
and the trans movement
is really shaken the course of what people
think gender identity is supposed to be.
- So, in one sentence,
you're saying that you
guys are not responsible
for the indoctrination
that's currently happening?
- Absolutely not.
- And in the second
sentence, you are saying,
we are shook by the fact that
you are responsible for it.
- No, you are shook that the
fact that the trans movement
has become what it is.
- And a movement that influences people--
- Powerful.
- All over the world and
particularly children.
And we see it in the fact
that the number of
young people identifying
as transgender, non-binary,
gender fluid, gender queer,
is skyrocketing.
Which means that children are
being exposed to these ideas.
And it's certainly coming from
institutions like the media,
like Hollywood, like our public
institutions, and schools.
So to say that that is not
happening or to deny that
that is the reality negates
the numbers that we're seeing.
- What I would say is
that the idea that there
is a single transgender movement
and ideology is disingenuous.
And that at its core being transgender
is about separating sex
from sex roles
and gender roles that are compulsory.
- Do you think that
children should be able
to transition medically?
- No.
- I think--
- It just really depends on
each individual situation.
They should be able to make
the best medical decision
for them.
- [Narrator] I am
comfortable sharing bathrooms
with the other side.
- Yes, I feel comfortable.
Safe? It might be a different question,
but comfortable.
Yes, I feel comfortable.
- What I think the bathroom
issue opens up is an issue
of predatory men taking
advantage of the opening,
that now they could walk
into a women's bathroom
or a women's locker room,
as we've seen happen in instances
like here in Los Angeles
at Wi Spa and they go
into a women's space,
they expose themselves to the women,
and then they say,
"Well, I'm a trans woman
and you've opened up this space for me."
- But we cannot blame
trans people for that.
And that's--
- Nobody's blaming you.
- That's the problem right here.
Because again, when you
walk into the bathroom,
I'm not interested in
knowing what you are,
what you identify as.
I'm trying to use the bathroom
and leave out of there.
What people have tried to say is that
when trans women go into the bathrooms,
they're being predatory.
And that is not the case.
- Nobody said--
- That is something you do
not blame on trans women.
Although you were not saying that,
when we talk about predatory behavior
and when we talk about like
the the predatory cases,
none of them have been trans women.
So let's just, I just wanna
make sure I know she's not,
I'm not, I know she's
not strictly doing that,
but because she said that,
I think it's very important that I bring
that out on the table and discuss that.
- But we have to have the conversation,
and I'll open up the question.
We know that if this legislation happens,
if we move forward with this move,
there are going to be men
who take advantage of it.
Now, I wanna ask you,
is your comfort as far as going
to the bathroom more important
than the female women
that will be victimized by this?
- Who said female woman
will be victimized by this?
- They will and they have.
- No, you're only assuming,
but the reality of it is--
- I'm not assuming.
- Again, when people are
going into the restroom,
when people are only
they're only focused on
doing one or two things.
And that's using the restroom.
- But you didn't answer the question.
Is your comfort more important
than the female people
who could be victimized by this?
- Okay, so let me ask,
let me help her answer the question.
Which one do you think I'm
gonna get the *** kicked
out of me in?
- It wasn't the women's restroom.
The issue that you're bringing up,
first of all is already
violating a whole bunch of laws, okay?
If somebody's exposing
themselves in a bathroom,
that's a whole different
environment rather
than just letting trans people in.
In California, it's right now
100% legal for trans people
to go use the bathroom of their choice.
So, I don't know what
law you're talking about.
- You're asking this question
as if I would not stand up
for cis women that were in the restroom,
and that's not the case.
Nice dodge there.
- I'm not dodging.
- But the reality of it is,
one thing I'm noticing
is we're reducing a lot
of these particular
conversations to genitalia.
And it's not about genitalia,
it's about safety.
- Yeah, her concern is the
possibility of predation.
And that's still a probability.
It doesn't matter if trans people are
using the restroom or not.
- Sure.
- But what you're concerned about
is that you're maybe really possibly
that people feel more emboldened
to put on women's clothing,
going to the bathroom,
but there's still violating
the law all over the place
if that's the purpose
that they're going in for.
(banging on chair)
- Yeah, so I didn't step forward because,
and I know in today's age,
this is gonna sound very
radical and you know,
but I just, I don't agree
with the whole transgender ideology.
And so for me it's encouraging something
that is based in what I feel is delusion.
And so I don't think that
we should be encouraging
that by allowing men
into women's restrooms.
- I think that if that's the case,
that to some extent
all gender is delusion.
If we're looking at
historically anywhere from,
you know, midwives after the enclosure
of the Commons in the 1400s,
having their whole trade affected
or brewsters having their trade affected.
And now we don't think
of women as, you know,
brewsters or that creating
beer is a womanly thing.
These all came from social conditions.
These all came,
a lot of gender regardless
of biological sex,
it didn't like naturally
flow out of our genitals.
And like, it was like,
you know, we're like,
this is how my genitals are,
so this is like how my gender's gonna be.
That didn't happen.
That's not life.
Like a lot of people who
are either transgender
or who are LGBT in general,
all my friends were girls.
At first, I just remember
there were a lot of things
where like, I would kind of like come up
against people telling
me that that's wrong.
Like that, whether it's something I like,
something I want to do.
It wasn't until kindergarten
that like someone
told me that I'm a boy and I was like, oh.
I don't feel comfortable
going to any bathroom
in this world.
Like in the current society we live in,
and to make trans women
the whipping girls of that,
I think that's disingenuous.
But I do think that we
need a systemic change
to make ourselves safer.
I don't really know anyone who doesn't
feel a little bit uncomfortable
going to the bathroom.
- And trans people are not a delusion.
Let's make it very clear.
We are here,
we've been here for ages,
we've been here since
the beginning of time.
We're in your history books.
And I don't think,
I think it's very disingenuous
to say that a whole
identity is a delusion.
- Well, I believe that
you feel like women.
That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying there is an objective truth
and I don't believe in
his truth, her truth,
their truth, my truth.
Like there is truth. And--
- Who defined that truth?
- And like it's already,
it's already defined.
And I, as a Christian,
I believe God is the one who set truth.
- But who defined that?
Can you tell me who defined that?
- God.
Living in the Bible belt
with religion taking center stage,
it's hard for a lot of trans
and non-binary folks like myself
to really be able to express who they are.
I had to really take on my
gender dysphoria in private.
I couldn't talk to my mom about it.
I couldn't talk to my dad, my siblings,
because ultimately I felt
like it wasn't gonna lead
to anything because there
wasn't a lot of education
in the cis community like there is
in the trans and non-binary community.
We're talking about a book
that was written by man
with his own bias.
- Who created chromosomes?
- Yeah, I'm personally not religious
and I believe in science.
- When we talk about chromosomes,
it goes back to the
conversation we were talking
about earlier about being intersex.
- But we're not talking about intersex.
We're talking about people
who were born as a male
and they tried to transition.
The whole fact that they're
trying to transition
into a female in the first place shows
that they aren't actually that that
or else there would be no
need to transition, right?
So you say, okay, I feel like a woman.
What is that? What does that feel like?
- Yeah, how does that feel?
- And how do you know?
- We're not saying, I'm not
saying I feel like a woman.
I am a woman.
- So, then why did you transition?
Why can't you just present
as a man but be a woman?
- I transitioned so I could be who I was.
I did not feel like I was the person
that I identified with when I was born.
So, I took the steps to
align my outside body
with how I feel on the inside.
What makes you stand up
every day and make you
identify as a woman?
Let me challenge you on that.
- I am a woman and I don't
like being called a cis woman,
because I'm not a cis woman.
I'm a woman.
I'm not a birthing person.
I'm a mother.
- So, get mad at the terminology,
not at trans people.
- It's your new terminology.
- But this is what,
this is what I notice
a lot of cis women do.
The terminology has
been around for so long.
Cis is a prefix.
Cis means same.
Instead of getting mad at
trans and non-binary people
for using updated terminology,
get mad at Webster.
You're not going along with
the times and being educated
on the different pronouns
and the different identities.
- You have to admit some of the pronouns
are kind of ridiculous.
I mean the,
to be with all due respect,
I mean, I mean you, you,
I'm sure you have to agree
some of the pronouns--
- I don't think they're ridiculous.
I think they're very expansive,
trans and non-binary.
People just want you to
respect they're chosen pronoun.
We are not trying to
force pronouns on you.
Just understanding that the terminology
is going to continue to grow.
If you're willing to educate
yourself and understand,
then you've got it.
- [Narrator] The ability to give birth
is a woman's greatest strength.
Can the disagreers or step forward?
- I'm not able to have children.
So, I'm still strong.
I'm funny, I'm physically strong.
I'm smart and I have a lot of strength.
I don't believe that having a baby
is the greatest strength,
'cause not all of us can,
I cannot have kids due to medical issues
from a medical procedure that
I had when I was younger.
And it's a hard subject to talk about.
It's doesn't mean, I
mean, I'm less of a woman,
but can we get another question?
I don't, yeah, I'm sorry.
It's, it's, I'm sorry.
- One of the things that I regret
was the fact that I would
never be able to do that,
but I was honored and the
ability to participate it
from the other side.
Women are amazing.
They don't just deal with that, so.
- While giving birth is not
a woman's greatest strength,
I do think that only biological women
are capable of going through that process,
and bringing life into the world.
- I need to push back on that,
because we're also
forgetting that trans men
and trans masculine people
can also give birth as well.
And I don't think it's fair
to just set it on one group
that says it just biological women
have that power to just give birth.
And we have to be very clear
when we look at the nuances of birth.
- I recognize that there are people
who have different identities.
There are a biological
women who identify as men
and then go on to give birth.
I would argue however,
that those people are
still biological women.
And I know that is something
that can offend many,
but that stands as my belief.
- So, the correct term is
actually cisgendered woman.
Cis means same.
It means that you identify with the birth
that you were assigned.
And so, you know, I
just really. really wish
that we would kind of be
a little bit more mutable
to the terminology,
because I think that's what
really is gonna open up
that dialogue and that discussion.
- If I may,
I think the crux of the conversation kind
of comes back to are trans women, women?
And I think if we don't agree there,
it's gonna be very difficult
to kind of keep the conversation going
or even agree on the points
that you guys are talking about.
Because if we don't believe
that trans women are women,
then the conversation kind of ends there,
in terms of whether they're,
like men can give birth or
not, if that makes sense.
- I'm not sure that's the case.
I feel like the ability to give birth
is not like the end all, be all
of a woman's like meaning and life
and herself and her personality.
And I think that if you
can acknowledge that,
I would also then maybe challenge the idea
that womanhood, as opposed
to like a female sex,
like womanhood is a consistent thing
that has always been one way.
- So, how would you define womanhood?
- You sound like Matt Walsh.
(laughter)
- It's a good question.
- Womanhood to me is about
standing in integrity.
It is about being
confident in who you are.
And me as a black trans woman
should not be a threat to you.
And what I see from a
lot of cisgender women
is they're trying to deem what womanhood
is supposed to look like.
I have my own perspective of womanhood.
We can coexist in the same world,
but the reality is we
get so stuck on parts.
Having a vagina is not the only thing
that makes you a woman.
I'm sorry.
It takes integrity, it takes courage,
it takes lifting other women up.
It takes those things to
begin to defy womanhood
and there's so many
other different things.
- Can I ask you a question?
- Sure.
- Okay, so if I were a white person
and I said blackness is
about integrity and courage
and kind of the same thing that you've
used to define womanhood.
And then I said, I wanna
transition into a black person
and I'm white and I'm
redefining what blackness
is to fit what I view it as, right?
There's no objective reality
of what blackness is.
Would you consider that appropriation
or do you think that's something
I should be allowed to do?
- I consider that dodging,
and I consider that
comparing apples to oranges,
because race and gender identity
are two, separate different things,
because when we look at race,
we have to look at many,
many different structures
of what whiteness and
white supremacy looks like
and how white supremacy can be manipulated
into other things.
And what happens is the closer you are
in proximity to whiteness,
you're able to weaponize
it against other people.
It reminds me a lot of
Rachel Dolezal who, you know,
masqueraded as a black woman.
It really did open up many more doors
of conversations around it.
But it's still wrong,
it's still not fair because
she was still ultimately
have a privilege that I
as a black trans woman
would not begin to have.
- What's interesting is that we are,
we're talking about race and gender
or as we probably like to
call it on our side, sex.
Race actually has a more
understandable structure
for people being transracial.
Race does actually exist on a spectrum.
I'm biracial.
Many perceive me to be black,
even though I am also
half white and half black.
We label people like President
Obama as a black president,
even though he is as well.
Race is never had binary markers.
It does exist on a spectrum.
Gender, however, does have binary markers.
As much as we try,
as much as we change the
way that we self present,
chromosomes are not going to change.
- Okay.
- And that's just a reality.
- All right.
I'm gonna bring up a little
point here because you
talked about the binary side of gender.
Well, I was born a little both.
I believe my,
I've never had my chromosomes checked,
but since I had, I fathered two children,
I'm assuming I have the
correct male of chromosomes.
So, I was intersexed and
there's a lot of reasons
that that happens,
none of which are
well-studied or understood.
But a friend of mine in
the pediatric trauma world
says about one in 150 kids
come out with some degree
of ambiguity in their gender.
For me that that appeared as
always feeling outta place.
And I'm, for the first week of my life,
I was in the surgical wards at, you know,
Naval Hospital in San Diego
getting pieces of me cut off.
So, and then they gave me testosterone
for the first 11 years of my life.
I wish the world were
truly sexually binary.
It would make it so much easier.
But there is a little bit
of a smear and you know,
as a trans person, I'm a very
conservative trans person.
I don't see the huge gender spectrum
that a lot of people in
the trans community do.
Do I feel better having transitioned?
Yes, absolutely.
I used to live in a little shell,
well, very large shell,
but, you know, but you know,
now I'm, you know,
much more open about who I am, you know?
Is that the only thing that
generally defines a woman?
No, I don't think that is the only thing
that generally defines woman.
- Right, I think there
are a lot of women who may
be on our side of the
argument who will try
to maybe invalidate your experiences
by saying you can't give birth
or you can't have a period.
And while those things may be true,
I'm sure there's a lot of
other different struggles
that you all are going through and yeah,
I would truly believe that you probably
are highly discriminated
against in our society.
And it is hard to be you.
It is hard to go through the
things that you go through
and have to deal with
some of the responses
that you get from people.
And, you know, it's not a
struggle that I would wish
on myself at all.
- Not a struggle I wish on my worst enemy.
- [Narrator] Trans women should be allowed
to compete in women's sports.
- I do think that trans
women have every right
to compete in women's sports.
When trans women are on hormones,
the hormones break their body down.
Having gender affirming surgery
breaks down down the body.
And so I think we really
need to be educated
before we jump to a
conclusion that trans women
are stronger than cis women in sports.
Hi, everybody.
- I find it interesting
that you assume the people
who disagree with you are uneducated.
And I will speak out against that.
I think the research
shows that trans women
do happen to have a biological advantage
against biological women.
Even though you are taking hormones
and that does start to change your body
and level things out,
we are talking about primarily people
who have transitioned post-puberty,
which means they do
have male bone density,
male wingspan, male hand size,
feet size, lung capacity.
All of these things are
going against women,
biological women,
when trans women start
to enter their spaces,
their sports, and compete against them.
And this is really concerning for me.
- I think for me it's
not a question of whether
or not trans women can compete in sports.
It's a question of how can
we change the institution
of sports in this country
to make it equitable
and to create more opportunity
for cis women--
- People need to start showing up.
- For trans women.
that's kind of like why I wanted
to actually ask y'all like,
what is your relationship to sports been?
- I don't think you have to
have a direct relationship
to sports to realize that women
are being affected by this issue.
And I do reject the idea of equity.
There is no way to come
about an equality of outcome,
which is what equity is saying.
There's a reason that women's sports
are less funded and less
watched than men's sports,
because men seem to excel athletically
and they seem to press the bounds
of athleticism way farther than women do.
We now exist on a slippery slope.
If it's female sports,
is it then female locker rooms?
Is it then female prisons,
which we're now seeing becoming
an issue here in California
where biological male inmates
are being put in female facilities,
because they identify as women.
We have to discuss as
a society how much we
give into the feelings of
wanting everybody to be accepted
and how much we are willing to do that
at the expense of biological women.
- I use myself as an example.
This is about how big I
was in junior high school
and early high school.
I used to be able to walk
up to a V8 engine block,
pick it up off the floor,
and set it on a table.
And if I was in power
lifting or weightlifting,
that amount of,
I mean that advantage
was just unbelievable.
I've been on hormones for 15 years.
Did it weaken me?
Absolutely.
Did my, you know,
my bone density really hasn't changed.
My muscle muscular hasn't changed.
And this is not a binary question.
There's a lot of nuances involved.
- I just want to ask a question
for what you were saying.
Can you throw out some statistics?
- I don't think you need
to have there, so there's,
there's an abundance of research.
There's even trans activists who agree
with exactly what I'm saying.
And your hormones can change, right?
And even she just spoke to the fact
that her bone density did not change .
- Yeah.
- In going on hormones
and changing these things.
- Yeah.
- And we can see it in sports
as we're watching them.
Leah Thomas is a great example.
- So if you can't throw
out the statistics,
we're not doing enough of the work.
And let's also be clear--
- I disagree.
- Let's also be clear,
there are some cisgender women
who produce high levels
of testosterone as well.
And so we really have to unpack it
from all different sides here.
- Can you produce statistics
about the bone density of biological men
and how it changes upon being on hormones
and whether or not it levels
out to biological women?
- I actually cannot because when I would
think of those statistics,
I would think it was BS to
be quite honest with you,
because the reality of it is we could talk
about statistics and the
research all day long,
but it's about experience.
We're gonna be looking
more at the experience,
because again, when we
look at cisgender women
who produce high levels of testosterone,
and who have been kicked out of sports
and been disqualified
from teams based on something
that they biologically cannot control,
then what are we really
talking about here?
- Well, we're talking about,
I mean data and that is overwhelming.
And we're talking about what is also,
we're capable of seeing
with our human eyes.
I think it's very clear
that if you compare
maybe you to the rest of us,
there is going to be
a strength difference.
There's going to be a
bone density difference.
- You don't know that.
But you're just saying
that you don't know until
can we physically do something
and just perceiving and assuming,
just because I look a certain way,
that's not fair.
Me and her could look the,
we could look completely
different or whatever,
but she may be stronger than me.
- I agree, but we know--
- She may have,
she have much more agility
and vitality than I do.
We don't know that until
you actually do it.
(talking over each other)
- And it's been done. We've
seen it numerous times.
- It's an assumption.
But we're only going on
assumption at this point,
because again--
- It's not assumption when we see,
when we see it,
maybe it's the news cycle that I watch,
but I see it a lot,
I see it quite often where they're
showing trans women beating,
I mean, them by far.
- And you don't see women dominating
in the men's sports, right?
You don't see trans men
going into men's sport
and just completely dominating
and wiping the field with them.
This is what happens
when you, in my opinion,
twist God's design.
And when you go against God's design,
you create these problems
that you wouldn't have
if you weren't going
against what God intended.
- I'm gonna take her
side a little bit on that
and let me say one more thing
and I'm supporting you on this one.
There are, I mean there's
a great deal of women that,
and actually there was a
lady in the last Olympics
that they actually disqualified
until she went on androgen blockers
to knock her testosterone
down to a female level.
Like I said, this is not a
a binary yes or no question.
And the whole idea of
messing with what you know,
God puts up, you know,
God put me up.
Okay, if you want to take that, you know,
and I had this conversation
with a very religious man
in San Diego and he was like,
oh, I don't quite know
how to deal with that.
- And God made you that way,
but he didn't make a lot of
the people transitioning.
- I understand.
- But God also understands my transition.
God, first of all knew what
I was gonna be in my life.
God already knew I was gonna be trans
when God put me here.
- So, why didn't he--
- I don't think it's fair
when people dip and dab.
Your relationship with God is personal.
- Yes.
- It's sacred.
- Let's keep it there.
- I don't think it's fair
when other people dip and dab
and other people's relationship with God
when they don't understand
what they go through.
God still blesses me as a trans woman.
God blesses you as a cisgendered woman.
God is embodied in me as a trans person.
I don't think it's fair.
Again, when we judge people's
personal relationship
with God, gender identity,
sexual orientation,
none of that matters to
a God that loves all.
- [Narrator] Gender dysphoria is real.
- I think it is obviously real,
because many people experience it.
But like any kind of dysphoria,
whether it's someone who
thinks they're overweight
or anything, I think it should
be treated as not reality.
Like if I thought I was obese,
I wouldn't want to go
to a affirming therapist
to tell me, yes, you are
obese and you should,
you know, get skinnier.
- Well, I had the opportunity
of working on the DSM4,
I think it was when we,
when we actually declassified
transgender dysphoria
from a mental illness to a condition.
You know, I had been,
at that point in time,
I had been cross-dressing
for 50 years and you know,
because that dysphoria was
there and every single thing I
did to try to drive it away didn't work.
I spent millions of dollars trying to
be the coolest dude in the world.
You know, I bought airplanes,
I bought everything that I
could to just show the world
how masculine I was.
It didn't work,
it didn't go away.
And I did therapy.
I purposely went to a therapist that
was anti gender affirming
and literally he said,
"You need to do this."
You know, and because
it was so deep seeded.
Spent six weeks as Gina with my son.
And at the end of that period of time
he asked two very fundamental questions.
The most important one was,
it's gotta be truly exhausting
for you to lead two lives.
And I was kinda like,
that kind of shook me to the core
that my 22 year old son
saw that better than I did.
So shortly thereafter,
I announced to my family
that I was gonna transition.
My wife and I separated because of it.
The kids were not necessarily shocked,
but you know, understood,
and have supported me quite well.
And my wife has actually
become a very good,
you know, very warm
supporting person for me.
- Gender dysphoria almost
made me kill myself.
And coming from Mississippi at the time,
there wasn't a lot of access
to gender affirming
resources, like hormones,
if I wanted surgery,,
whatever the case may be.
And a lot of us trans folks who don't
have access like that,
a lot of us have to do sex work to be able
to afford some of these things as well.
Me coming up at the age of 20
and I knew I had a
serious gender dysphoria.
I did things to my body that I should
have went to a hospital to do.
That is something that's very, very hard
for people to understand.
A lot of us commit suicide,
because of gender dysphoria
and so it hits our community a lot harder.
- I do think gender
dysphoria is very much real.
I think the issue that's happened,
especially in the space
of science and research
is that we've looked at gender dysphoria
and said the only source of
care that we can go through
is blind gender affirmation care.
And a lot of the research shows that this
is not the route to go into.
And other countries that have decided
to do nonpartisan
research, Sweden, Finland,
have decided that yes,
gender affirmation care
should be an option,
but it really should be the last resort
when it comes to treating
people who appear
at clinics with gender dysphoria.
You know, a lot of
conservatives will deny and say,
well, gender affirmation care
does not make them happier.
And in many cases that is true.
But there are the cases
like your yourselves
where the gender affirmation
care does make them happier.
- You know, I know a lot of people
that have transitioned,
have un-transitioned.
I've talked with a gentleman
at a religious right convention one day
and he was sitting there
screaming how Jesus
got him out of his gender transition.
And honestly, that was
the saddest man I've ever
talked to in my life.
When I looked at him straight in the eyes,
and I said, "You know, hey, I
don't agree with what you say,
but I 100% support your
right to say that."
And he just literally broke down crying
on the steps of the Supreme Court.
- If I could interject
really quickly, I do--
- No, absolutely not.
- I feel as though the medical profession
is actually inching towards a space
that is going to become unsafe for people
who try to express their gender dysphoria.
Because now we have young children
coming into clinics expressing this,
who by and large,
statistically about 60 to 70%
grow out of that dysphoria.
But because it's become a political issue,
where many activists
have come in and say no,
you blindly affirm,
you affirm to to the
furthest extent that you can.
Rather than going through a
more comprehensive process
with these children,
we have a, what I think is
a medical tragedy happening
against young people in this country.
- [Narrator] I have
been sexually harassed.
- Yeah, I think in our society
it's so sexualized every,
everyone and everything.
And I think we owe a lot
of that to pornography
and just media.
And I think the kind of acceptance
that I do see more so in
the LGBT community of like,
you know, sex is great
and let like everyone talk
about it and there's no shame
and everyone's just blurting out.
You know, the fact that
we're perpetuating a culture
that's frankly, in my opinion, disgusting.
- So, are you talking
specifically about LGBT people?
- I'm talking more so just
about this sexual revolution
that the more sexual you are,
the more partners you have,
the more open you are about
your sex life and everything,
the more like liberated you are.
What is consent?
Like people are coming
outta the woodwork saying,
you know, I was violated,
this happened to me and,
but they like drove home with that person.
And I'm not blaming them,
but I am saying those
lines are being blurred,
because of our just flagrant
disregard for any kind
of like actual relationship
prior to the sexual encounter.
And I think a lot of people
are being exploited left and right.
- True sex positivity has been powerful.
It has helped us to grow
and learn about our bodies
in so many ways and
learn safe sex practices
in so many ways.
What I would blame for rape culture
or for a lack of good boundaries
or that kind of thing is we
live in a capitalist system
that has taken things like sex positivity
and mangled it and repackaged it
and made it a whole other
thing than what it actually is.
- I was sexually harassed
for five years by a woman.
That does happen,
'cause I'm pretty sure it's gonna be
where men this men that,
it's hard coming from a man,
but to me it was harder
coming from a woman,
'cause it wasn't expected.
Like I understand, you're
gonna probably touch on that
about how men are more
on the predatory side
or the more harassing side sometimes.
But I just wanna let let you know
that it does happen with women as well.
- All through my life, you know,
world's biggest kid in junior high school,
I basically was harassed continuously
for being gender nonconforming.
Back then, you know, everybody
in junior high school
took showers together.
I basically had a
permanent welt on my bottom
from people snapping towels at me because,
you know, I wasn't as well
endowed as I probably should be.
I had, you know, pretty
good size boy boobs
and basically was just
unhappy being in sports.
But you know, it happens everywhere.
I have been sexually assaulted,
and it didn't work out
well for any of them.
It's real, let me just put it that way.
It's absolutely real.
- Yeah. I think it'd be
hard to find a person
who hasn't been sexually harassed
in some way, shape, or form,
whether you are male or female.
I think it's an experience
that we all share,
because we are in somewhat
of a hypersexualized society
and people love to make
those comments public.
I am a podcaster and I do
social media for a living.
So as you can imagine,
the onslaught of sexual
harassment is quite, quite vast.
- From a very young age,
I've had this recurring nightmare
of something happening to me,
trying to warn people
and no one believes me.
When you're not believed that
you are a desirable person,
and I really don't think rape has anything
to do with desire,
but when you're not believed in that way,
when trans women are
experiencing trans misogyny,
we are the ones who are least believed
when we are sexually assaulted.
And it just feels so
disempowering and so terrifying
when you know that you are someone
who is seen as hypersexual,
as inherently sexual,
as inherently predatory.
And yet at the same time
you're seen as someone who,
can be isolated and sexually
assaulted and not believed.
- I don't think there's
anything inherently predatory
about trans people.
And I think oftentimes when we are talking
from a conservative perspective,
it gets misconstrued as
viewing you as a threat.
And I hope that that never comes off.
And I think that allegations
of sexual assault,
regardless of who they're coming from,
should be taken seriously.
- Common ground.
. I think we agreed on something.
- Found common ground.
(laughing)
(intense music)
(music ending)